it doesn't work okay so everyone my name
is Pierre Glazer I work at inria
which is a Research Institute in France
and actually most of my team does like
research in machine learning from your
imaging data but there is a small subset
actually in this team of ninja that work
mostly on open source project and you
must know them because uh I mean a bunch
of them maintain the secretary library
machine learning and actually my job is
to like improve the performance like
among other stuff of scikit-learn
when it's asked to do tasks in parallel
either multiprocessing with the
threading or multi machine so i'm gonna
talk about like how we collaborate with
the whole ecosystem than pi Python and
bunch of other libraries to make multi
processing and multi machine computation
faster for everyone so the first section
will be basically like a walkthrough
about like why parallel processing is
important in machine learning then the
second part is kind of gonna be a
catalog of all the like different
libraries that you'll see that do like
multi processing and that scikit-learn
for example uses and then the last part
actually will be like like the most like
leading-edge advances that we actually
pushed forwards and python 3 up to 8 and
that hopefully you'll get be able to
benefit from ok so i just realizing this
doesn't fit well but anyway so python
hopefully by the third day of your
python you guys all know that python is
in a mood like used by at least a decent
part of the users to do like data
analytics and machine learning
I think Python is really cool to do like
basically interactive development and
like fast iteration of like data
analysis so there is like I don't know
huge like ecosystem of open-source
libraries that got a lot of fun in tune
in the last ten years
numpy that used like by the recent
matrix by 200,000 people pandas and of
course I could learn and actually so I
this is for the whole like they don't
know this presentation why is like
parlor computing so important machine
learning I think it's because parallel
computation append kind of a lot in
machine learning because machine
learning at the core is kind of
statistics and it statistics to tend to
repeat independent operation to make
more reboosts like to insert these into
a bunch of stuff and sometimes you can
want to spend space to explore also and
so what we call this like it's kind of
independent computation that we can run
completely independently we call them
embarassingly parallel tasks and so
embarrassingly parallel attacks happens
a lot as I said in machine learning they
happen like in cross-validation random
forest ran the forest for example you
want to fit a model like an Impala
consists of a bunch of trees so kind of
wanna fit all these trees completely
independently and so I mean completely
like conceptually speaking distributing
this task is not like shouldn't be a
burden right because like you have all
this task completely independent from
each other you have resources like let's
say workers processes machines or
anything and you want to distribute them
so I mean there is no communication
between the processes like it's it's
technically super easy and it should be
made acting easy for the users like
using psychic plane that would like to
another like machine learning inter code
and so as a conclusion I think paralyzed
action is like if learning is completely
ubiquitous and it's super easy to enable
like let's say for example you wanna
train a club random forest classifier
you can train upon four cores simply by
using the EM Java render so I mean you
know it's a one-liner it's super easy no
to get into a little bit more details so
I think there's a little bit overlapping
of this talk with Auto Talks maybe a
little bit the talk of Victor but I
still get a little bit you know kind of
dive into it to make sure everyone here
is up to date with that parallelism
on a single machine exists under like
two different forms you can either
create different processes so basically
for any different piping programs that
will have their own memory space or you
can have one second Python program
executing different threads in parallel
so actually corresponding multiple
threads in one single pregnant program
seems like the smart way right because
like I don't know use like a specific
memory you have anything like in a
single processes slider so why don't we
use all threads right like in this
example here like you have like I don't
know for example three threads that's
all I have to fit for example different
trees of a random forest and so they all
can appoint to the same data right so to
fit the model here they always have the
same data but actually the problem here
is a Python in general
I can
forces threats to rent sequentially so
it's not always the case right for
example if using empires I buy an empire
of supplies are like written in native
code and so because they're running
native code they can release this global
interpreter lock that prevents the
threat from running in parallel but I
mean you can always like hope for it but
it will not happen all the time right
when you create like your own Python
program you don't know in advance unless
you dig into the source code of the code
like the libraries you use you don't
know in advance whether or not like your
threat are gonna be able to run in
parallel or sequentially I think it in
this safe way to an angle parallelism in
the code is actually to run process
based parallelism so you have different
types and processes with their different
memory space and because they're
completely independent process if you
have multiple cores of your machine you
can actually ensure that like different
sequences of fighting bytecode are
actually gonna run in parallel and
that's Assam typically if your code is
CPU bound and not IO bound like you're
gonna get a speed-up so like this team
just saw straight so many different
copies you have to make of the data
because at this point all processors
have different memory space so you have
to like dump your data to all the memory
specs of the different processes which I
mean that's too overhead first it like
increase the memory footprint of your
program enough like generally like a
bunch more of data just hang out in the
RAM and also there is kind of overhead
of transferring the data from the main
process to the other which can you know
be kind of long especially if the data
is very large there is I mean shared
memory is a thing and its beliefs is
gonna be a thing in 3.8 it's also as a
thing before but you guys probably
didn't know it because it was kind of
hidden not even in the standard library
just through like some kind of weird
hacks that we used to do in scikit-learn
so we use to enable shared memory
between processes but let's not to talk
too much about that because it just adds
like some more complexity just guys
letting you know that's you know it's
the thing and hopefully it also kind of
helps to make multi-processing faster
this graph is a graph of benchmarks of a
different model fitting of scikit-learn
models so it's a 2d graph so basically
each point if this graph represents one
machine learning model the x-axis is the
time it took to fit this model
sequentially and the y-axis is how long
it took to fit this model using four
different workers
so I mean you will accept most of the
points in this graph right to be close
to the green line because the green line
represented like the ideal speed-up so
the green light the question is y equal
X divided by 4 so it's basically two etl
speed-up that you can expect from
running a model in parallel between
running and model with one worker so
hopefully all the points are distributed
along this line of course it's not gonna
be the case because you're gonna have
all the like data passing and stuff but
hopefully we're gonna hope that in
practice it's here so you also know
these two colors here you have purple
points and yellow points the yellow
points are like points where the
parallel back end was processes so we
did not run different threads we run
different prototyping processes the
purple points were points where the
parallel instances were threads and as
you can see not all the points are
completely distributed close to the
green line most of the points are in the
kind of good enough zone that's the
green zone right there close to do like
optimal speed up we can get but some of
these points and you'll notice it's only
purple points are like far awake and are
outliers and the red line here
represents the point past this red line
like above this red line we actually
have no speed up from feeding a model
using like different workers so this is
like worst then like this points
represent cases we're fitting a model
using different worker is worse than
fitting the model sequentially so this
could be considered as bug but as you
see only like purple points so this
represent typically global interpreter
lock contention that can exist in Python
so I think like the kind of takeaway of
this graph is that process based
parallelism with always I mean
asymptotic click and a procuress
speed-up is the data is not too big and
running your model is not too slow sorry
it's not too fast and that's why I think
we have to like kind of focus also
making multi processing faster is
because it's for now the end of this
safe way to an ability process parallel
processing in Python and also I think
there are like many different concept
like many improvement as you do when you
improve multi processing you also
improve multi machine because the
concepts are the same you have to pass
that around between machine between
process it doesn't matter so much so as
soon as you do an improvement for multi
processing you do also an improvement
for multi machine execution
the second part of this talk is gonna be
more of like an offical catalogue of all
the libraries that provide multi
processing possibilities in your code
but I mean more than a catalog I think
it kind of represents the development
workflow that my team did when they
wanted to actually have multi processing
code brand in scikit-learn right they're
starting from using like standard
library libraries such as multi
processing and then realizes sometimes
it's just not enough so we ended up kind
of creating our own and then build upon
it to make it like super easy for data
in this I think the like you know also
key takeaway of this part I'm sorry I'm
doing the conclusion before even I ran
the slides but the key takeaway of this
part I think is to realize that a lot of
stuff we do was kind of to ease the
development like the the usage of Milty
processing code for data scientists
[Music]
first so let's talk about the standard
library in the standard library there is
a module that caused a lot of pain to
people like making sure like python runs
of different platforms
it's called multi processing so multi
processing is kind of like a huge module
providing like wrappers around like
system code like sensory system calls to
create processes and to make this
process communicate so you can like
create a bunch of data structures to
make the process communicate you can
create the processes so like for example
you can create queues and also you can
synchronize the processes using large
there's a very very rich libraries but
it's also coming kind of a low-level
library and I think when you think about
like embarrassingly parallel tasks so
embarrassingly parallel it's just
independent computation run what have to
like your cat that can be run completely
in parallel with no Camille sorry with
no communication between the workers
I think multiverse is like paralyzing
embarassingly parallel tasks programs
have clicked your common structures like
technically what you want to do is to
create a queue queue all the tests that
you want to paralyze on to we want to
paralyze embarrassingly
we spawned a bunch of workers that will
just get tasks from that queue and then
have the were clear send back the result
to the main process and this happens
whatever you use cases as soon as you
deal with embarassingly parallel tasks
so I think this should be expected away
and I mean I didn't think that
multiprocessing developers thought that
and
actually created a class which is called
a worker pool so the impede pool class
that abstracts all of this away and with
which you interact when you want to run
embarassingly parallel tasks so let's
say for example I want to greet all my
friends I have two friends only Alice
and Bob
so I kind of kind of map these greetings
using the pool pulled up map great Alice
and Bob and then here that friends in
parallel and you don't have to create a
queue you don't have to create processes
it whole happens completely smoothly
the problem with multi processing is
that in some cases it's not super
portable I'm I think sometimes we forget
Windows because I I think I mean for
example I like developing Linux but
actually a lot of data scientist they
run on Windows and what data scientists
do on a day-to-day basis is interact
with Jupiter notebook so what happens
usually is they launch a notebook in the
browser and then they just run code and
then interact with it so they run their
code they figure out that's not exactly
what they want they rerun cells and then
they run machine learning models but
everything that happens in a reputed
notebook happens in an interactive
session and the problem with
multi-processing
is that it's not super good at
paralyzing code that was created in
interactive session and actually when
I'm not saying is not super good it's
just not possible
so that's the first big concern I mean I
think I mean I don't have the correct
numbers but I think like 50 percent of
the secular users are on Windows so we
cannot really like let them away you
know another problem is that even on
POSIX system actually the way to start
processes is not I think POSIX compliant
is only used for it and not exactly
afterwards so it actually causes crash
with some external libraries that are
very useful when you want to enable
performance in your code and especially
the new version of OpenMP so this is
another problem and that doesn't happen
on Windows it happen on POSIX systems
and also the multi processing pools are
like not super user-friendly when it
comes to like work for and expected
crashes so crash like workers can
suddenly crash for example if the seg
fault or if they consume too much memory
that can be killed by the US and in this
point multi processing pools are just
gonna wait for them to finish where
they're just crash so they're never
gonna finish you're gonna chill out and
in a way it control C or something which
is not great so because of all these
problems we decided to and
these were like kind of problems at the
core and it was not super easy to fix
them upstream so we kind of decided to
actually like create a bunch like a
whole new library from scratch this
library is not created from stress
actually it's rated from confluent
futures but I'm not gonna like talk
about that so this library we've created
and that's actually used by psychic
learning school low key so low key is
another library that provides worker
pool access so it's a third-party
packages it supports all Python version
hopefully we're gonna stop support for
piping 2.7 so please guys update to
Python 3
it has consistent behaviors unlike Linux
on Mac OS and of course on Windows and
it works an interactive shell so I mean
it's the way to go if you want to
paralyze code for that's used by data
scientists because and I cannot stress
this enough like working interactively
is the key advantage of Python and we
have to support it
Lukie API for worker pools is kind of
the same as another library in the
standard library that's called
concurrent features so I would say it's
a drop-in replacement although I'm not
like a hundred percent sure at least the
syntax is very very similar so for
example here you paralyze a task using
like computers and here you're paralyzed
that paralyzed at eyes using Loki is
basically the same syntax right why we
use concurrent feature and at Loki same
co-curate fritters are some problem just
like on interactive session and etc so
we cannot use concurrent feature we have
to create a new library it's not because
we like to code is because we have to
finally the last part of this like huge
catalog of different libraries is called
I'm gonna introduce you guys to drop Lib
so job leave is library that's built on
top of Loki and that's what's created to
kind of ease the development workflow of
data scientists job lead is actually
what interacts with scikit-learn in
scikit-learn codes scikit-learn doesn't
interact directly with Loki it interacts
with win with job Lib when it wants to
paralyze tasks and so it's a parallel
computing library any among the like
very cool feature that it includes
oh sorry I think the killer one that
actually I did not know when I started
using it is this bed moving with
memoization so basically if you want to
paralyze a bunch of tasks that are CPU
they take a lot of time and let's say
for example I don't know you want to so
this example is gonna be stupid but you
want to greet a thousand friends right
and so you started winning all your
friends in parallel and at some point
like at the 500 friends you crash right
well Joe bleep is gonna remember that
you did all this to us that maybe you
know it may take a lot of time to read
your friend you're gonna have them or
you their kids or the exciter etc so it
may take a lot of time and Joe bleep
actually like got all these results from
this task and store them into disk so if
for some reason the call to Joe bleep
can have failed in the middle where
you're executing a bunch of tasks all of
the result that you already computed
will be stored in disk and so if you
rerun the call you won't have to
actually rerun all the tasks all the
tests that you already ran you only have
to like get the result from the disk and
it has that you didn't run already well
you have to run them but so actually
this is really really really useful
another useful feature of Joe bleep
that's nothing to Loki is like optimize
transforms an empire array as I said
like data scientists always worked with
anti arrays and if you want to actually
enable good speed up from multi
processing you have to like make sure
transferring Empire rates not taking too
much time so Joe bleep takes that in
accounts and also has kind of a back-end
agnostic user API so it's really easy to
switch from a trading back-end to a
multi processing back-end and here is oh
like two line code snippet that show you
how to do it the last part of this talk
I absolutely don't know how much time I
have left okay ten minutes is great so
the last part of this talk is going to
get a little bit more involved it's
about like what happened recently in the
multi processing community in Python and
what were the problems in in this
community that we actually managed to
fix and not socialize but code wise so
from now on I think you understood that
what's important when doing multi
processing and when constructing multi
processing code is making sure that the
data you transfer from process to
another are transferred fast and also
because you have so many processes that
holds like the same copies of the data
making sure that the footprints of the
overall system of workers is not so here
so high so they started I think the two
main things I wrote down from the last
year and
so a life thing which is a fuse
typically like pool hanging because like
worker crashes or anything but I'm not
gonna call and I'm not gonna talk too
much about this last point I'm gonna
talk about the first two points one
disclaimer before I start this is all
about cpython
I'm sorry for your pipette folks from
the ironpython or anything this is all
about cpython
maybe actually disorder implementation
don't even have those problems I don't
know so when you actually want to like
transfer data from one process to
another you have to do in a person
that's called sterilization so think
about when you run a Python program you
have a bunch of objects that are in
memory right and this object that kind
of for what we call an object graph
right because an object can hold a
reference to another object I don't know
like I'm look I am an instance of a
class and I have an attribute that's
like another instance of this class so
you'll have kind of a link between the
two vertices that has this object and so
at the end if you look at the complete
memory layout of your Python program
it's a big huge object graph right and
so my use case is I have an object in
one process and I want to like send it
to another process what you have to do
if you want to create like serialization
for this process is to make sure all the
objects that are presented the object
graph and that are leaked at some points
to the object you want to serialize are
also properly sterilized so saralidze
action is kind of for recursive
operation where you make sure all
objects that are linked to the object
you want to sterilize are also
sterilized and at the end you it's
completely atomic objects that don't
hold any reference to other objects so
stars like integrals integrals don't
hold any reference so they're kind of
like beliefs of the graph you know it's
not a graph is a three disappointment
it's like but anyway so this little
seems like Anna illustrates what you
want to do you want to get an object and
then you want to cover it to a format
that's suitable for inter-process
communication bytes is a good format for
inter-process communication so here I
have an estimator maybe like of a
scikit-learn class and I'm serializing
it to a bunch of bytes and then this
bytes I don't know can be sent it to a
pipe and got back for another process
that will recreate this estimator by
executing the instruction that are
contained in these bytes
this whole thing of course you don't
have to do it right there is a module in
the standard library that does it for
you it's called pickle
actually pickle is a protocol and the
pickle module is an edition of this
protocol and so here is a very simple
code snippet where I have a list of 3
elements I can serialize English the
pickle dot dumps and then I have a
sequence of bytes right and if I launch
a completely different Python process of
the snippet in the below either can be a
completely independent Python process I
sent him this bunch of bytes and using
pickle dot load I can completely
recreate the original objects so this
kind of illustrate the point that you
know from one process to another I sent
a list so that that's pretty cool but
the problem with the pickle
implementation is presently the pickle
module is that by design is kind of
limited and it has a I mean it's not
limited to random stuff actually because
for random stuff we're saralidze engine
wasn't introduced generally you can
submit a patch to a trim and they will
be happy but there is one thing for
which develop like Piketon developer
really like kind of sensitive and don't
want to push that feature and if Sai
mean and it's understandable it's not
it's not connect to your rationale but
it's not possible with pickle to send
interact likely interactively defined
function so let's look back at the
workflow from a data scientist you
create a bunch of function and then you
want to execute them in parallel and you
want to iterate fast so you don't want
to leave a session and then rerun or
something you just want to have a bunch
of code cell that you like modify and
run on the fly and then send it to
workers and so typically in this
situation pickle will fail as sending
this function so it's just not possible
using the sterilization like pickle
module to actually run function in
parallel when your data scientists
working on interpreter notebook
especially on Windows typically this
example here when I create a function
completely dynamically that's a lambda
won't work since me a pickling error I
don't know if you've ever seen that
error guys like run running your code
isn't ever I see a lot of time but uh
that's it's frustrating and so in
practice many distributed computing
libraries and in general also
scikit-learn
they don't rely on pickle internally
they rely on pickle extension that
canopied this problem to make stuff
faster not faster actually just to to to
I mean to make stuff faster ultimately
but just basically two parallel ice code
so in practice tasks for example that's
the second logo or Ray that's the first
logo psychic learns part or prefix all
those libraries that don't rely on
pickle internally they rely on pickle
extensions such as for example cloud
pickle pickle here in the last snippet
example completely manages like to
sterilize this function but here's the
problem with pickle extensions actually
the pickle module so is implemented
actually in two different ways is
implemented as a C extension like it's
so is it's in descendant library but
since ability with potency and in pure
Python and the version in in C is
actually 30 times faster that's
realizing big objects than the pure
Python one so I mean when you extend
pickle you don't want to extend the
Python version right we want to extend
the C version because they all provide
the same classes so at the core
sterilized engines of objects in Python
is like calling metals from the picker
class and both the C module and the
Python module have the same picker class
but what you want to extend when you run
Python it like pickle extension you want
to extend the C picker class but sadly
that's not possible
at least that wasn't possible spoiler
alert like in Python 3.7 for example
here you had if you were using cloud
pickle to rely on the pythonic picker so
let's say I want to serialize a large
list I'm gonna take 30 times more using
cloud pickle that using pickle for
sterilizing sterilizing the send done
object so it's very frustrating and
actually this was causing a lot of
slowdown in scikit-learn when sending I
don't know for example vocabulary in
using TF a dive IDF vectorizer these
kind of things so this was definitely
something we had to work on to make it
better and actually in Python 3.8 Python
extensions can no extend the see
optimize pickle module so I mean this is
really an achievement because it helps a
lot when like sending large object not
numpy array but large list or like dicks
that typically are attributes of
scikit-learn estimators if we do exactly
the same benchmark now impact in 3.8
we'll see that I mean the the increase
in speed is not significant
I think the T takeaway here
is that the order of magnitude is the
same and it's not one order of thing you
can slower using your cloud pickle that
using people so this is definitely
something that getting proven packing
throughout eight one last feature
actually that's even maybe more
significant is the burst of pickle
protocol five so pickle has a bunch of
protocols basically each time you want
to do like and if a huge addition to the
picker protocol you have to create a new
protocol there was already like five
protocols and the last protocol addition
was made by a Python Coraopolis called
Antoine and that free kind of realized I
mean he was not only to realize but I
mean bunch of people realized that
pickle originally was kind of created
for like on this persistent J of my ten
objects so let's say you have Python
objects in memory you want to store them
into disk but it's not how its use right
now how it's yours right now actually is
as a way of communicating data between
Python workers so it's not storing
objects on disk its communicating data
and because it was not thought of that
way the RAM usage was suboptimal we were
making like spurious memory copies and I
mean it actually causes worker to be
killed by the US when taking too much
memory and this was causing tons of
deadlock and it was a pain for like
developers of distributed computing
libraries such as desk and drop live and
all the others so actually this problem
was completely solved in pickle protocol
five thanks to a new edition that's
called the pickle buffer
it's a low-level objects that you will
never see but basically using pickle
buffer ensures us that local P are done
when they're Pingel loading like large
contiguous buffer that are hold by an
empire raise and our tables and so
typically panda's data frame or
scikit-learn estimate oh that old
references to these objects will be
sterilized super fast and also we'd like
no overhead of memory or something like
that so it's really a big addition but I
think it goes like even one step further
actually it's not only like main memory
optimization or something it allows
delegation of like the kind of compute
heavy part of sterilization to
third-party libraries so I mean you guys
probably know what an empire is but at
its core and the PI race is just a bunch
of metadata like the shape of an empire
right
the flags and then a huge contiguous
data buffer right and so what I want to
do personally when I develop pickle is
like I see this Empire rate coming and I
want to sterilize it and I wonder like
when I see all the light subjects the
sides like the flags just write the
shape I'm gonna give it to pickle
because pickle is good as just
reconstructing Titan objects but when I
see this huge data buffer I just want to
take it and sterilize it my own way and
then in the process like that recreates
these objects I will take the two
streams the streams that from the pure
pickle and the streams that I created
when I serialize optimist like optimally
my my object and that's actually what's
a pickle protocol five also does it
although what we say out of bounds
realization of big data buffer and
that's very useful for all like
distributed computing libraries such as
desk ro and scikit-learn and obtuse so
there is our can draw a conclusion I
think what we could have says is that
just parallel computing makes stuff
faster in general in scikit-learn
that from what we've seen in this graph
which back into use this a problem like
it's a problem specific question so you
actually have to like try out different
of do's and to see what works better for
you depending on what bound is your code
and also working with upstream is worth
the hassle
it makes the ecosystem safer so please
guys work with upstream
thank you very much for the very nice
talk
I've definitely lived a lot we have time
for a few short questions I didn't
understand why the C Python developers
then don't care about the interactive
users it's so it's I think it's a it's a
very very very difficult question
actually a lot of people complain about
the security aspects of pickle pickle is
sorry I've known to be like unsafe and
so typically when you define a function
interactively you cannot serialize them
as a reference to their module because
the main module is not present of all of
your workers when you create a function
in the main module of a process you
basically generally when you serialize
function like for example like another
exponential function from the math
module when you sir like this function
the byte string will only contain
instruction to get back the function
from the math module so it's a very
lightweight there is no code serialized
but if you actually interactively create
a function there is no way you can get
it from the main module of the other
process because it just won't be there
so you have to serialize actually the
code so I mean when you sterilize
interactively defined function you
sterilize code objects and your cell
lies like Python virtual machines
instructions and this can be seen
somewhat as unsafe so I mean there are
like kind of fundamental problems to
sterilizing interactively defined code
and actually in the documentation of
code pickle we kind of strive like we're
sorry we cannot stress the fact that you
know capital is not super safe and that
you shouldn't like although like redo
clerical objects if it's not like
verified and secure and everything I'm
afraid we don't have a time for any more
questions these things thank you very
much
give me one
you
[Applause]